family left behind grieve
they don't deserve it
she's a very lovely lady
this woman says her aunt is among the
four victims a man and a woman in their
60s a woman in her 40s and a woman in
her 30s
police were called to an address on
delaford road in the early hours of the
morning after neighbors reported a
disturbance
inside the house they made a dreadful
discovery
of four people
who had been stabbed
despite the best efforts of officers and
paramedics
all four people were sadly pronounced
dead at the scene
this neighbor told sky news he heard
screams over the sound of his television
i heard screaming
i don't know what time it was
it was after 12 o'clock i know that
the mp for camberwell and southwark says
it's left the community here shocked
well this is a very quiet settled
peaceful lovely neighborhood and
everybody is absolutely shocked nobody
expects this to happen anywhere but let
alone in a neighborhood like this
a murder investigation has been launched
and there are calls for witnesses to
come forward
police say they arrested a man in his
twenties at the address here on
dallaford road he remains in custody at
a police station in south london
officers say all four victims and the
suspect were known to each other
sadia chowdhury sky news in southwark in
london